citizens of the reject Nation it's time for
a very special koi's comic Corner because
Spider-Man is my favorite Comic character so I'm
Overjoyed to be ranking his movies now please do
leave a like subscribe leave in the comments
your ranking and yes we are going to include
across the spider-verse now there will be no
spoilers for across the spider verse I promise
not a one the rest obviously spoilers those
movies been out for a while but no spoilers
for across the spider-verse as we rank all 10
of the Spider-Man films number 10. Spider-Man
3. you knew this was gonna be this I mean there's
not really another answer I do think Spider-Man
3 is a bit better than some people might give
it credit for it Is Not Great by any means but
the Sandman stuff really really works a lot of the
darkness of what Spider-Man's going through works
but there is enough negative there is enough
that doesn't work it has to be the bottom of
the barrel I didn't love the Ultimate Spider-Man
casting of Topher Grace I didn't love the dancing
I didn't love some of the choices that were made
especially at the cost of not just Spider-Man but
all the characters in this film when Peter Parker
is making out with Gwen Stacy in front of spider
man before he even gets the Symbiote it's hard to
see him fall from grace because it feels like he's
already fallen from Grace Sandman however holds
the test of time and I do feel like no way home
redeemed a lot of what the Sam Raimi movie was
supposed to be and I would love honestly for Sam
Raymond to get the chance to make the Spider-Man 4
he wanted because I wanted to see the Spider-Man 3
with Sandman without venom pushed in there a lot
works but more doesn't number nine The Amazing
Spider-Man 2 this is also kind of just where it
needs to live this movie is Studio interference
the movie now this movie came out pretty deep into
the MCU already being established and I feel like
they were trying to figure out what to do with
Andrew Garfield as Spider-Man there was talk of
an Amazing Spider-Man 3 there was talk of bringing
Andrew Garfield as Spider-Man into the MCU I feel
like there was just so many what-ifs that it cost
the movie a lot of its own Integrity I don't blame
Mark Webb I don't even blame some of the writing
choices I blame the overall conversation between
the studio and the writers and the director and
the leads now that said all of those the negatives
the positives are ample the relationship between
Gwen Stacy and Peter Parker is maybe my favorite
Spider-Man relationship it absolutely sings the
moment with the Green Goblin and the 121 on the
clock she literally Falls and the clock says
121 and that's the issue she died in that is
a genius Easter egg for Comic fans there's also
a lot of beautiful lore explored here the use of
the z-axis not quite as good as the first Amazing
Spider-Man but really does work here the fighting
with Electro is visually stunning and this is
maybe the best web swinging in any Spider-Man
live action film you heard me I think this is the
best live-action web swinging and he moves like
Todd mcfarley and he has all the sensibilities of
a spider and I still think Andrew Garfield is our
best live-action Spider-Man So Amazing Spider-Man
2 is number nine but I do have a place in my heart
for it that's higher than a lot of people I
think number eight Spider-Man far from home
Spider-Man far from home is I think a lot like
Amazing Spider-Man 2 a movie that has a lot going
on that doesn't quite know where to land those
things it is not just a Spider-Man movie it's a
Spider-Man movie in the MCU that uses some of the
characters that has some ramifications but doesn't
quite know where to put them I think that all the
Spider-Man films in the MCU use the Spider-Man
villains very well not all of the films but the
MCU films really know how to get these characters
to sing I think using the Tony Stark backstory
with Mysterio was genius I think Mysterio is a
prophetic villain I think we're getting closer
and closer to not knowing what our reality is I
think using a character from the 60s that doesn't
quite always work on the page and making him even
better on the screen absolutely elevates far from
home that being said I don't feel like Spider-Man
should always be out of New York he's a friendly
neighborhood Spider-Man why can't he be in New
York I didn't want to see him go to Europe I
wanted to see him in New York that story would
have worked so much better if it ended with the
Statue of Liberty I know we got there in no way
home but I really wanted some iconic Spider-Man
lore to be explored in the streets of New York
and I feel like we still haven't gotten there
with our Spider-Man now by the time we get to
no way home we start exploring where that could
go but I do feel like it was a poor decision to
take Spider-Man that we just got out of New York
I feel like homecoming set him up for one thing
and then he got put in The Avengers movies I feel
like he came back from the Avengers movies they
took him to Europe Spider-Man still hasn't
gotten to be our guy yet and far from home I
think was the biggest example of that not working
as much as it should have number seven spider man
the first Spider-Man and this is where I'm gonna
start getting some heat samuramy's Spider-Man is
so important it is very foundational that does
not mean it's better than the next six films and
I know there is a Nostalgia for some things and I
know sometimes that's deserved and I'm not saying
it's a bad film but I'm not thinking it's better
than the next six this movie really really really
started a lot of things after blade and it really
allowed for the universe we live in now to work
but there is a lot of things that don't work
for me I think that Sam Raimi absolutely loves
the Silver age Spider-Man but when you're mixing
the Silver age Spider-Man with the ultimate era
of Spider-Man with the 2000 stuff it does kind of
feel disjointed I think Toby Maguire his inherent
anger as Peter Parker works for a lot of writer's
take on Peter Parker I don't see Spider-Man as
this boiling rage character unless he has the
symbiote suit on I know it's very popular to
love your characters in black suits and make
them angry and make them come back from the
dead looking at you certain other character that's
very popular in comics but it doesn't mean that's
the character and I really think that the first
Spider-Man started a science trajectory of this
angry nerd that was mad at being a nerd as opposed
to someone that wanted to help everyone as opposed
to someone that wanted to find the right way I
also think Green Goblin was poorly directed as
the character I think that we saw later what
Willem Dafoe could do as the character I think
it was a product of its time which costs it some
and I have to look at this movie as 2023 looking
at Spider-Man not what 2001 gave us to Spider-Man
in 01 create a superhero movie It's amazing we got
the Green Goblin at all but now I have to put the
next six above it as much as I love Spider-Man as
much as I needed that movie to be as good as
it was and much that movie shaped me at the
exact right age I just can't put it higher than
number seven number six The Amazing Spider-Man
yes I put the Amazing Spider-Man over the first
Spider-Man because I think this movie understands
who Spider-Man is the biggest complaint I've
heard about the actual portrayal of Spider-Man
is that he's cool Andrew Garfield is a cool guy
but he's not playing cool that's just who he is
Peter Parker Mary Jane Gwen Stacy and black cat
would like a word with you if you don't think
Peter Parker's cool being smart and being cool
aren't mutually exclusive things he dresses in
a sweater vest in the 60s because people dressed
in sweater vests and he wore glasses because he
needed glasses he was a nerd to Flash Thompson
and to Betty Brant and some of the cool kids
but he didn't stay a nerd that wasn't what he was
as a character he has nerdy qualities but I hate
that everyone sees him skateboarding as like well
he's not Spider-Man there's so much in this first
movie especially with the lizard that really ties
into the science elements I love how much of a
scientist he is and most of all and this is a very
for me black and white issue I love Gwen Stacy
and Spider-Man's relationship I mentioned Mary
Jane Gwen and black cat this is a very romantic
character I do not love how much we remove the
Romantic elements from these characters in the
MCU and Amazing Spider-Man didn't remove it at all
it was a fixture it was a point of pride in this
movie Mark Webb made 500 Days of Summer that's why
you put him on Amazing Spider-Man the relationship
between Emma Stone and Andrew Garfield was so good
it translated into real life this movie loves love
and it loves their relationship and Spider-Man's
a tragic figure he's a Shakespearean character
that's always about loss and overcoming loss and
striving through adversity if you don't love his
life you don't love his adversity if he doesn't
have the When Stacy relationship worked when she
dies it doesn't matter I never really really
believed in Mary Jane and Peter Parker in the
same universe I just didn't I didn't think they
worked I didn't think they had chemistry I know
they dated in the movies it didn't translate
it translated The Amazing Spider-Man his web
swinging is immaculate that scene of him and
the sewers doing all the Todd McFarland poses
like he does in the second film all of that to
me is Spider-Man it had Studio problems it had
writing problems there are problems but to me
The Amazing Spider-Man is more Spider-Man than
the first Spider-Man number five Spider-Man two
this is with good reason one of the most beloved
superhero comic book films of all time and it's
number five that's how good the Spider-Man films
are putting this list together was insane because
on any other top 10 list you'd be hard-pressed to
find where to put the Spider-Man movies because
they're near the top Spider-Man 2 is one of those
oh my God that's when we fixed comic book movies
for a reason the Alfred Molina stuff absolutely
Works The Daily Bugle is amazing all of the stuff
in New York I love Sam raimi's New York all of
those elements are absolutely Spider-Man there's
so many iconic moments I remember to this day like
him with the pizza him with the train him with
the Aunt May elements there are things that I love
about this movie but what keeps it from being in
the top four is a lot of the token wire stuff that
I just don't see as Spider-Man for my personal
interpretation of the character mixed with scenes
like the train scene which starts out amazing the
dock fight on top all that's great but then the
very heavy-handed like maskless Spider-Man not a
single New Yorker is gonna sell him out yes I love
that he represents New York yes I love that Sam
Raimi understands that Spider-Man represents New
York but the suspension of disbelief between the
first and the second is a giant leap that no one
ever finds out Toby McGuire slash Peter Parker
Spider-Man and there's a lot of those decisions
made in the second film there's a lot of the
things that make Sam Raimi movies work like the
horror sequence with Doc off that don't quite fit
the film for me I love that sequence and I love
it in the movie but when I look at Spider-Man I
don't think of those elements I'd love to see a
Sam Raimi directed Crave in the last hunt I'd
love to see some horror stories of Spider-Man
but Doc Ock never felt like the horror character
to play with I didn't attach to the science as
much as I attached the horror and there were
so many elements like Daniel Day Kim being his
assistant which is crazy to look at there's
so many science elements that could have been
dove into more it's number five five it's high
up it'd be in the top 10 of damn near any list
but the top four even higher for me number four
Spider-Man homecoming and this is maybe my most
controversial take on the Spider-Man lore and that
as much as Alpha Molina is beloved for good reason
he's an incredible villain in the Spider-Man
movies but for me I think the vulture did all of
the things that people love about Molina's take
but a little bit better for me like for example
in the comics the big twist on Norman Osborne
is that he's Harry Osborne's Dad it's someone
you didn't expect all these things and then they
did that in the movies with another flying green
character and made it the love interest father
they tied in all the John Hughes elements of
him being a kid and having that inherent fear and
respect for a paternal figure nothing scarier than
meeting your prom date's dad and then it's the
vulture tying that youthful energy into a Twist
from the comic books but subverting expectations
so we're surprised and that whole scene in the car
where Michael Keaton deftly overpowers Spider-Man
verbally and the lighting shows you who they are
it reminds me of the first Spider-Man when at
Thanksgiving Green Goblins wearing Spider-Man
colors and Spider-Man's Green Goblin colors but
with lighting and then you've got the vulture
himself who's literally Scavenging the remnants
of the MCU that's the perfect way to bring in a
Spider-Man villain you tie it into Tony Stark in
a really fun way which they didn't get in very
well with Mysterio I love the lore built in the
mythology and the texture and the quilt that is
the MCU weaving into Spider-Man like a web and
I think that honestly Tom Holland is Spider-Man
even though I don't love that he has the tech suit
even though I don't love that he's always like the
right amount of power and we don't get him to be
the friendly neighborhood Spider-Man this is the
movie we got the closest I love him getting the
bike and the churro I love him figuring out his
town I love him figuring out all the elements of
like going to the bodega and then like you know
making sure it doesn't get destroyed in the next
there's so much right about Spider-Man homecoming
I feel like it gets overshadowed because Iron
Man's in it but Iron Man isn't as distracting
as people remember that's just what the posters
were if you watch it he's not in it as much as I
think people remember and it does tie beautifully
into this now I do think there's Spider-Man in
the comics which I consider Andrew Garfield
there's Spider-Man in the Silver age which I
consider Toby McGuire the best possible way to
bring Spider-Man into the MCU was Spider-Man
homecoming and that's not to mention the fact
we got not one but two Shockers we got Donald
Glover tying in his whole Donald for Spider-Man
campaign and being basically the proto-prowler and
being one of the best tie-ins of all time and him
getting webbed to a car that has a license plate
with his character's first appearance there's so
much love for Spider-man and homecoming that it is
easily top four for me it was actually hard to put
it here number three into the spider-verse again
I said after five it's gonna be just hot takes
into the spider-verse is a five-star film which
means the next two are also five star films for
context I've given 22 films five stars three of
them are Spider-Man that's insane this character
has so much that we identify with and that's what
this first movie is about into the spider-verse
is anyone can wear the mask I'm gonna be totally
honest I was worried because the spider-verse
comic storyline felt like okay how can we make
more Spiderman and to sell toys and this did the
opposite of commodification this made it like oh
wait these Spider-Man have all of these plot
points and narratives that really really work
getting rid of Moreland and telling the story that
they needed to sell for the movie was bold because
of that that was the comic storyline instead
they were able to in an animated movie that's
under two hours explain quantum theory for adults
and children while telling the most compelling
Spider-Man story to that point and it's able to
introduce so many characters you love immediately
it brings you spider Gwen who much like in my
opinion miles elevated beyond the comic material
I love miles in the comics I love spider Gwen in
the comics I never was like these guys are better
than Peter Parker I just didn't connect to them as
much because I'd been with Spider-Man Peter Parker
my whole life this movie showed me they're all
Spider-Man and this movie showed me how they're
different and it's not just their powers it's who
they are as people and it gives me all of that in
less than two hours while being one of the most
visually stimulating and stunning movies I've
ever seen while holding up to this day is one of
the most re-watchable movies I've ever consumed
while being a source of joy and inspiration for
anyone that watches it and giving us Nick Cage as
Spider-Man Noir there is so much right about
into the spider-verse that I don't know that
it could be number three on any other comic book
movie list if I ever rank the top 200 comic book
movies it might be three there too this is crazy
love this number two no way home and here is where
everyone's gonna be like ah recency bias and that
movie's not that good and without the tie-ins with
those characters it's nothing that's not true the
movie does tell the finale of a six movie origin
which is so ambitious and so bold it is a story of
power and responsibility that puts our Spider-Mans
that we've loved our Spider-Man that we've loved
for our entire child in adulthoods as the Uncle
Ben figures it makes Aunt May such a a more
important character in our MCU Spider-Man's life
while making those Spider-Mans the Uncle Ben's it
gives us meme moments that actually actually work
it gives us dialogue that explains away plot holes
from the past it gives us nostalgia in a way that
is more authentic to plot than I think any recall
ever I love that Nostalgia is so important because
I think it's really important to remember the
good times but it's also important to make new
good times this movie uniquely reminds us of the
good times while building more new Good Times Tom
Holland is at his absolute best here the scenes
of him in anguish the scenes of him fighting the
Green Goblin sequence where he's literally tearing
a building down around him the feast building all
of the things that he's able to do with his
incredible acting and physicality Elevate Tom
Hall and Spider-Man while we have the supporting
characters of Andrew Garfield and Toby Maguire
also my problems with Toby Maguire went away in
this movie he even acknowledges his anger being
a negative then Andrew Garfield acknowledging
the way he's had to cope and deal with things it
gave me an Amazing Spider-Man 3 and a Spider-Man 4
verbally while improving Tom Holland and I haven't
even mentioned the villains we get beautiful new
takes on Old characters we get the best Green
Goblin I can possibly imagine we get Redemption
for Alfred Molina with the way his character
landed I love Alfred Molina's dock I love him even
more here I actually felt the adversity with the
tentacles I actually felt Sandman not knowing
how to handle this situation I actually felt
all of these characters trying to figure out why
a Sinister Six would exist which is exactly the
kind of characters they are in the comic books but
even better to have it translate through actors
giving us so much behind their eyes this movie is
a perfect three Spider-Man movie it is a perfect
almost Sinister Six movie it is a perfect MCU
installment and it's doing all of that at once
with Incredible visuals and incredible love for
a character that I've loved since I could read I
learned to read with this character and Spider-Man
no way home made me feel like I was reading what
my childhood promised me could be made into a
movie while as an adult and I could not possibly
Express how much that movie means to be number
one I cannot honestly believe I'm saying this
because says what I just went through trying to
encapsulate how much I love no way home I didn't
think anything could top it I honestly didn't
think anything could top into the spider-verse
so the fact that no way home affected me so much
I I was flabbergasted I've only seen it once but
I think this is where it lands across the spider
verse is my favorite Spider-Man movie across the
spider verse is something I need to do a six hour
dissertation on there's gonna be a spoiler talk
tomorrow on this very Channel there's a spoiler
free video already up of me reviewing this movie
and a spoiler on my own channel so there's lots
of places to hear me deep dive because frankly
I need to to do it justice but in brief this movie
does everything that into the spider-verse did for
more characters this movie does it with characters
that I was more invested in one because I was more
invested in miles and Gwen this go around because
of how good a job the first movie did it has the
opposite of the sequel problem instead of trying
to go bigger and louder and Bolder it accomplishes
bigger and louder and Bolder but its goal is to
go deeper the goal of this film is to feel for
all these characters more not sensationalize
these characters it happens to be perhaps the
most impressive bit of Animation I've ever seen
I think it is the most impressive translation
of any medium to animation of all time I cannot
fathom how this movie exists but all of that is
secondary to the characters all that is secondary
to how much you feel for these characters and it's
not just the characters we met in the first
Spider-Man 2099 has so so much going on spot
is one of the villains I never thought we'd
see on screen and he is utilized here master
and that is one thing that I didn't expect from
this movie it has I think and I'm not gonna be
hyperbolic here I've been thinking about it for a
week I think this is my favorite Cameo appearance
in the history of movies and that's personal to
me it's not gonna be everyone's favorite Cameo
appearance but it's my favorite Cameo appearance
in movies and it does all of that while doing some
things I can't talk about until this boiler
review because those things are so much and
they're so impactful but it never leaves behind
our two leads and this movie is effectively a
spider Gwen movie as much as it's a Miles Morales
movie this movie is about how you wear the mask
this movie is about the world of Spider-Man and
what Spider-Man is to me is family and it's power
and responsibility and it's taking care of your
loved ones and this movie takes the time to take
care of its loved ones and us who love it we're
Spider-Man's family we're as loved ones we care
about this character so much this movie's a love
letter to us from Lord and Miller this movie makes
sure that we are receiving all of that and and
and I did and uh I I cried so much and I cheered
so much and I believed in visuals I didn't think
could translate and I I just saw what I've always
wanted a Spider-Man movie to be I want to thank
them so thank you and everyone that made across
spider versus my number one Spider-Man film of all
time I'm excited to talk about it tomorrow on the
spoiler live chat I'm excited to talk about it on
my own spoiler view I'm excited to talk about it
in the video that's already up in this channel the
non-spoiler because that three minutes was hard to
keep to three I wanted to go like 20 but Craig's
sitting right there and he's going koi how long
is this video gonna be like 82 minutes and I was
like no blow that maybe 20 and like 30. but that's
beside the point I love to cross the spider verse
I hope you love across the spider verse I've only
seen it the ones and I usually wait to rank them
until I've seen it twice but I think that's where
it lives and I'm so excited to see it again and
I'm so proud to be a Spider-Man fan so uh check
out across the spiderverse it is now playing see
it big see it loud all the all the catchy things
and let me know in the comments below what you
think your ranking is but in all honesty I would
see it in IMAX and I'm gonna go see it again in
3D because I saw it in 2D and I'm curious how it
translates let me know in the comments what you
think of across the spider verse let me know what
you think of my list let me know what your list is
like comment subscribe and koi's comment Corners
back you guys asked for it I was so excited to
see all the comments one in koi's common corner
this was the best thing to come back to much
much love I'll see you soon with another one
foreign